as a brand new youtuber there is so many
things to learn when it comes to
understanding how to do youtube right so
today on the growth video live show i'm
going to be sharing with you three tools
that you must have if you want to
succeed on youtube all that more coming
up on the growth video live show
[Music]
welcome back to the girl with video live
show my name is heather torres the host
of this show and we are in the countdown
to grow with video live if you're
joining us right now want to let you
know that we do have a special for you
if you'd like to join us in person or
online for grow with video live you will
actually get five percent off of your
tickets and early bird is ending soon so
you want to make sure you lock in your
in-person or virtual ticket to grow with
video live 2022 now today's episode is
actually brought to you by vid iq i have
more coming about that in just a little
while but i'm not doing the show solo
today no no no i'm actually joined by my
friend and lovely co-host he is the
senior executive producer and one of the
personalities of a channel with over a
million subscribers that's right i have
dan from vid iq here today dan welcome
to the growth video live show hey thanks
for having me we decided to make this
show happen as we count down uh to grow
a video live vidiq's actually one of our
main sponsors this year we just got the
t-shirts and the swag in it looks so
cool i'm so excited for vid iq um you
guys are doing a training actually
during one of our lunch sessions that
i'm so excited for our audience to be
able to participate with but dan we're
breaking down
three tools that people need to have if
they want to get started on youtube and
i say they should have these tools um
because this is going to help them cut
down the learning curve of trying to
figure out what to do right on youtube
so we're gonna jump into it um first off
dan is actually the youtube studio the
youtube studio did you know dan that the
youtube studio is available on your
phone and your desktop did you know that
i think i check youtube studio my phone
more than any other app it's worn out
the button is worn out it doesn't work
half the time
yeah i uh i'd have to say that for me
particularly um that one and instagram i
feel like i'm on constantly just
checking the updates checking to see
what happened um and there are a couple
things that i love about the dashboard
or i love about the youtube creator
studio now for people who are just
jumping on youtube this is actually
different
than the actual youtube itself talk me
through that just a little bit dan and
then i'm going to break down actually
four things that i love about the
youtube studio
so the youtube studio
app and the back end on the desktop is
different in that if you are a youtube
creator you're probably very familiar
with it depending on how invested you
are in making content you're probably uh
more familiar with youtube studio than
you are the youtube home page
at least that's how it was for me for a
bit uh there's actually uh this is one
of the rare cases where youtube has a
separate app for something remember when
shorts came out and we thought oh maybe
they'll make another app for youtube
shorts and they just embedded it in the
normal youtube app well youtube studio
is actually a separate app and what it
does is it helps you
get a hold of everything going on in
your channel right now you'll upload
videos through there you'll check up on
your analytics uh it's kind of an
all-in-one
place for the back end of your channel
yeah it's my favorite and someone's
asking really quick um does it work for
uh spanish language channels and from my
understanding dan that it works for all
of the channels it's an app in the
integration of the language that you're
using at ricky so you do have access to
that um as a channel uploader is that
the right word as a content creator how
about that we'll say content creator um
one of the things that i love so much
about the uh youtube let me get to the
right page here oops that's not the
right page uh one thing that i love
about the um studio first is the
dashboard i think what's really cool is
that youtube actually creates this
really great dashboard and um and let's
talk about this just a little bit dan
what do you like about this dashboard
right when you hit the actual homepage
of the youtube studio uh my favorite is
the latest video performance i think
it's
at a glance this has so much information
but just just seeing well i guess it
depends on the day right seeing a three
out of ten is a very good day
sometimes you get on then you see a 10
out of 10 and it's scrambled the jets
panic everyone panic you know figure out
can do we have to change the thumbnail
what's going on but either way
you get that the second you open it and
i love that and the other thing i love
is that youtube has been inputting
different uh videos and tips and things
like that in the dashboard so that is
also very awesome yeah one thing that i
love so much i'll just zoom in a little
bit here is here at think media we say
go for green
go for green so i love just right away
that youtube is giving you actually what
matters to youtube like if youtube's
gonna serve you up this information
they're telling you what they're quote
unquote grading you on right like
remember when you used to
write papers in class and you'd ask your
teacher like what is this actually going
to be graded on like is it my vocabulary
is it how many sentences like what am i
actually being graded on and youtube
teacher is letting us know right away
that views matter most impressions click
through rate right how many clicks
you're getting on it and your average
view duration so i love that youtube is
showing you right off the bat exactly
what is important another thing that i
love about the youtube studio is
actually that you can keep an eye on
your real-time analytics so if you want
to keep an eye on your real-time
analytics you go to that analytics page
and write in the overview it actually
says right here your real-time analytics
so what's cool is that to see in the
last uh 48 hours we've had almost
quarter million views happening on the
channel now when you click into like an
actual video uh let's say we go to a
video here it's actually going to tell
us something that's best video that is
an ad so let's not click on that one um
if we were to go to let's say this one
here uh you can see right here real time
and last 48 hours and you can go here
last 60 minutes 105 people have watched
this uh
this video dan why do you why do you
think that's important to know like
real-time analytics
it's a really good way to kind of check
the the pulse of your channel but also
like the pulse of the content right and
that's doing well right now so for
example i have some videos that i made a
long time ago that still get decent
hourly viewership and whenever that
happens for a long enough time and a
video continues to get older and older
and yet it still keeps popping up in
your real-time stats you have to ask
yourself am i making enough of that am i
making am i doubling down on that kind
of video and real time is kind of at
least for me where that research kind of
begins because that's where i know to
start looking in terms of different
videos
i like real time exact same reason i
also like it too because i love graphs i
don't know if anyone else loves screen i
love graphs and this helps me just to
see like man it really peaks between at
lunch time wow look at that every single
day it kind of peaks right at lunch time
so if you are doing you know a marketing
messaging to people if you're sending it
out in an email if you are posting on
social media trying to get people to
watch your video maybe post knowing that
they're first gonna get on uh you know
maybe it's your community tab or a way
that you want to help market that i love
being able to see real time what is
actually peaking when does that work and
that helps to really evaluate into the
marketing of how we're even doing um our
channel the next one actually uh youtube
gives us is the impression click-through
rate so the impression click-through
rate is this beautiful graph one thing i
do love about the youtube studio is the
graphs i've already said that but i i
love
that and this is actually a great
graph to see what matters most why don't
you break this graph down just a little
bit dan so we know kind of what we're
looking at here um when we when we're
saying that we can see the impressions
but then it goes down this weird funnel
what do these numbers mean for us dan
yeah you mentioned funnel it's kind of
the marketing funnel for your channel
right so
impressions would be the first time
somebody is shown your video now that
could be
any number of ways right so you open up
the home feed and there are videos in
front of you each one of those videos
just got one impression from you right
so you get a lot of those because you
only can pick one of the eight to ten
videos that you're seeing right so you
get a lot of impressions
so the click-through rate is the
percentage people are actually clicking
on the videos once they see them right
so
you're getting 42.1 million impressions
and then the views from that you're
getting 2.3 million and then from there
it's the average view duration how long
are they going to watch the videos so
the watch time you're getting from your
impressions across your whole channel in
the last 28 days is 130 000
uh plus
hours
i love that and um one thing for me
specifically i i love seeing this number
increase so i want to see these numbers
going up i want people to be clicking
through more we're actually going to
talk about that in our third tool that
we're going to share with people of how
do you increase the clicks like what's a
way you can increase the clicks so make
sure you stick around for tool number
three
but lastly i actually love that it gives
you
your traffic source so on the other side
of the same exact graph we're seeing
this traffic source and this is really
cool because it's showing us one that
for think media specifically um youtube
search is a big deal why is that well
youtube is a search engine and so it's
great to know that we have over uh 45
of views happening on our channel coming
from youtube themselves this gives me
hope too when i'm seeing things like
suggested videos browse features um and
what are these three right here why are
these so important dan um as a youtube
content creator to really be keeping an
eye on
well it really depends like i like to
think especially the top three there as
like the different buckets that your
content kind of lives in right so
you you can make a video very
intentionally for youtube search and
then you can also make a video very
intentionally for browse and there's of
course crossover uh search and browse
are going to show up probably the most
for a lot of people and then videos
being suggested alongside other videos
like that's what all these means so
right now think media is getting half of
its views just from search so and and
that's not a surprise to me you make a
lot of videos on your channel that
really cater to search very heavily
which is why we saw the views per hour
as high as they were in the last 48
hours because
people are still getting answers to
their questions and then of course when
people watch your channel enough your
videos are going to show up in browse i
didn't search for them they're in front
of me and then you're getting 14.1
percent of your views from people who
are finding the browse and it kind of
goes down the list from there external
being i would say one of the most
confusing because
someone could take your video put it on
their favorite discord server and a
whole bunch of people in that discord
server click that would count as an
external view
yeah i just love to click through even
more you can see even more uh ways that
people are are coming to i like this one
too playlist look at this impressions by
playlist so it's showing that and then
uh it says short speed here now it's
blacked out for us here we actually do
know that we're getting that and youtube
right here vinnie says um the youtube
short speed is number one for me in the
traffic source um i would say that
youtube shorts for us specifically um
while it brings in a lot of views
they're short views so they're not long
views they're not hour-long views where
we do have videos on our channel that
are on the lengthier side that are
getting way more quote-unquote views
because of that so are you seeing
anything particular on your channel dan
um with bit iq in relation to shorts
versus regular videos
we don't put shorts on the vid iq
channel uh at least not yet it's
something i i've been saying we should
do and then of course without like a
proper strategy that doesn't really make
a lot of sense so we've had them on
another channel which of course that
means the shorts views over there are
very high on my personal channel i have
a mix going on and no i will not share
the personal channel with you as it is
personal but i do have a mix going on of
short form and long form content and
when i stop posting shorts for a while
that graph dramatically changes very
quickly you know browse takes over but
when i go back to making shorts
brows and shorts are constantly fighting
for the you know the top spot there and
uh yeah if you make shorts that graph
looks a lot different for you yeah uh
indie annie says uh what's best
suggested or browsed let me break that
down just a little bit dan i know you
briefly went over it but would you say
one is better than the other
both are good it's it's kind of it's
it's where your videos are showing up
right so if you get a video that's being
suggested a lot you've probably made a
video about a topic that
other people are also covering but
there's always more to know right so i
would imagine if you're watching this
video right now think media there's
probably a vid iq video or video from
channel makers or some somebody else
like that
showing up in the suggested feed and
that's a good thing you know that means
you're covering topics that people are
looking for right
browse is what i think you should always
want you should always want people
regular viewers to find your videos and
visit you from the home page or wherever
and
you know coming to the channel and then
you want your videos
suggesting your own videos which you'll
find a lot of your suggested views are
just that they're your videos being
suggested
within your own content which is great
that means you have a very full content
catalog
yes and that's actually that's what you
want to build you want to be building a
whole catalog a whole piece of that so
ricky says um should i post shorts on my
channel uh should i put shorts on my
channel or make a separate channel for
shorts ricky we won't actually be going
into that too much on this one because
we really want to cover the tools but we
actually have talked about this in some
of our previous videos here on the show
so make sure that you're subscribed so
that you can go back and watch those
different uh videos where we did
specifically talk about the shorts i
know once we started talking about short
stand it's like it's like candy and it's
like a kid in a candy store every time
because it's the cool new hot thing
happening on youtube but it is just one
feature
of the plethora of abilities that happen
on youtube so i want to get into
actually tip number or the tool number
two
but dan we've got girls video live
coming up and we are actually in under
30 days now for growth video live i
can't believe it uh if you want to get
your in person or virtual ticket to
growth video live this is our in person
and virtual conference you can do that
at uh
growthvideolive.com enter the code g w v
l show and you could get entered into um
five percent off early bird pricing is
going away which currently right now is
50 off of tickets so you get 55 off of a
ticket if you decide to come to grow
with video live and i just want to give
you a little teaser of what this is
going to look like and then we're going
to get into tool number two
this thing is your gateway to get out of
the thing that you complain about but
people would rather complain about how
it is than put in the work we need to
start understanding how big this
opportunity is because for everybody in
this room he will sit back in 20 30
years and regret if you didn't execute
in this era it has never been a better
time in the human race ever to actually
just go all in on you
[Music]
regardless of what you're trying to
accomplish you've got to tell the world
about it this is now the world you're
not betting on this you're finished
[Music]
this is your golden era right now
there's never been a better time to be
here
this is the greatest golden era of not
only business but life
i desperately want you to win
but this is on you
oh my goodness
i mean that i feel so cool every time i
see that video it's so much fun uh back
in person uh we had someone said vegas
baby that's right greg we are back in
person in las vegas in 28 days we're
gonna be hosting grow with video live
vidiq is actually a major sponsor of
growth video live this year so if you
would like to get access to vid iq which
i highly recommend we're gonna be
jumping into that in just a minute you
can do that by going to vidiq.com
forward slash thing because tip number
two or actually tool number two dan is
vid iq and you have a little bit of
experience with vid iq of being the
senior executive producer and one of the
personalities of a youtube channel of
over a million subscribers so dan why
should people uh um get that iq but not
even that what are some of the cool
features of how to use this as a new
creator you know i really like the
direction that vidiq is going right now
because we have
new tools that we've been promoting last
year and this year and we're only
going further and further in this
direction of helping people with
something i've always struggled with
when i was coming up on youtube which is
coming up with ideas good ideas that are
actually going to get clicks so right
now there's a lot of reasons to have the
software but right now it's
really if
video ideas are something that you've
been struggling with or titles as i'll
show you here in a minute uh this is a
fantastic time to be uh getting yourself
some vid iq but iq.com
think oh sorry yes vidiq.com think uh
because the reason i want you to
download this if you're a new customer
and get the full access to boost here is
uh because we have you just pulled up
daily ideas i have my screen if you guys
want to put it up uh
and of course i don't have there we go
daily ideas you get 50 ideas if you're a
boost customer i'm not going to oversell
you on this though let's just check it
out real quick so
in the content creation process a lot of
this can start here for you right you're
you're just trying to get some ideas and
so our algorithms will tell you like
well this has very high potential how to
grow your youtube channel fast youtube
channel reviews now you're thinking to
yourself i don't make videos about how
to grow my youtube channel fast dan okay
that's not helpful that's okay because
this is for the vidiq channel uh if you
install this and you authenticate your
channel it'll be for your channel so
if you have a gaming channel or you play
minecraft you're gonna get a whole bunch
of ideas about minecraft so if you like
this idea you can save it you can
dismiss it so we can save it and it goes
into our saved ideas list we have all
kinds of ideas that we've been
stockpiling uh mostly through
demonstrations like this but we do use
this tool and it does help us quite
often a lot so sometimes you get ones
like this that are insanely long and
that just doesn't work heather it
doesn't work so actually i'm just gonna
roll right through and tell you when
that happens
you don't you don't have to panic
anymore because we have a new feature
that is going to help you with that i've
zoomed in on my screen so i'm still
getting used to all the wonky controls
here
so
this is actually a video that we share
internally just to kind of help some of
our creator partners and stuff learn
this new tool it's called the ai title
generator i pulled it up because there's
a private video so if i mess it up
nobody gets hurt uh but
we have this title here and if i were to
hit get ai title recommendations it
would treat this title like kind of like
a search bar and it would come up with
some ai title recommendations so
let's say let's just get rid of this
title we're just doing research right
now okay so you have a video in the
background it's on private you can do
all the research you want with this tool
and uh i have a title i pulled up
earlier so how to promote your youtube
channel this was one of the ideas from
the daily ideas tool
i'll show you it came from the saved
idea i liked i liked where this was
going earlier
uh
it was one of these
uh well i can't find it now but how to
promote your huh oh no you're good keep
going this is great i'm excited about
this tool yeah it was the long one so it
was right in the middle here live how to
promote your channel this probably came
from live streams and things like that
but how to promote your youtube channel
is something i've seen a lot of people
ask right so
i type this in and i'm like that's a
perfectly serviceable title okay but
what if there are other directions we
can go maybe i haven't recorded this
video yet so i hit this button
and we get some very interesting
suggestions and these are different than
the last time i checked so it has a lot
to tell us here we can keep hitting
refresh on these but how to promote your
youtube channel like a boss so give it
some emotional pull
how to promote your youtube channel like
a pro
five tips now wait a minute five tips
for your youtube channel like a pro now
i i
i'm writing the script for this video i
actually only have
four tips but that's okay i didn't think
to put this in a listicle form and now i
am thinking about that so when you like
a title you can go ahead and click use
it'll populate in here but how to
promote your youtube channel seven tips
from the pros so a whole bunch of ways
to break it down if you don't like any
of them like i said you can refresh some
of them again it is ai it does it does
like to fumble sometimes but how to
promote youtube channel is pretty much
what we already have in there
simple and easy steps so make it sound
nice and easy for everybody so
daily ideas
and the ai title generator are just
these two companion tools that i find
myself using all the time now
so again if you are a boost customer you
get access to everything you're seeing
here if you're a free user you get
limited access to these tools uh more
details on our website but
if you're new and the link's down below
uh heather how many more how much do i
have more to have time for oh you keep
going because this is amazing and i love
all of the tools inside of vidiq can i
say yes over the weekend dan i was on
messing around with vidiq because it's
just such a robust tool when it comes to
titles and headline generators and ideas
and when i say like i i remember for the
last seven years trying to come up with
youtube titles
based on
headline generating books that i
downloaded and like understanding these
literally vid iq just serves them up on
a platter to me which is such an amazing
thing i actually have a homeschool
channel also and i came up with things
like why homeschooling might be the best
decision you'll ever make this is
literally what this is what vidiq is
giving me very very very detailed ones
um homeschooling guide to your options
top five homeschooling tips that will
make your life easier so it's pulling on
not just the search-based piece that we
teach here at think media which is
understanding keywords and titling but
it's really encompassing
why people click on videos when we were
talking about you know impressions and
click-through rate in those pieces this
is one way to actually increase your
click-through rate is because of these
cool titles and it's just blowing me
away
i have a whole list now of titles that i
want to use on like three different
channels because they're coming out so
good that we're not having to put in
that extra time and effort we're just
clicking a button and literally vet iq
is generating those titles for us
absolutely i mean and and the examples
you gave make so much sense we're at a
time where thanks to the pandemic and
everything happening a lot of people
probably started thinking about
homeschool for the first time you know
what it what if
you know i taught my kids from home how
what are the steps there and
that kind of thing feeds you know these
ais that we have that are trying to get
you ideas so now you're seeing all these
ideas coming in like hey these have some
pretty high potential and you can see
why so
the next tool i wanted to show is you've
made your video about how to promote
your channel the seven best tips
whichever title we went with and once
you do that part of the research there
it's not over it doesn't have to be you
can continue to learn from that video
and that's why i just love to promote
the channel audit tool again free users
have limited access to this but uh full
you know full blown boost customers will
see all kinds of features uh one thing i
like to look at is just the at a glance
info right we talked earlier about views
per hour well here are your videos
that are getting the most views per hour
right now we this one went out today at
the top here which my cursor keeps
freezing a little bit but you can see it
there uh so that one's getting it's
doing very well for us and then the
engagement rate
is also this is for the last 30 days
rob's made a video here that is getting
some incredible engagement
and
heather real quick like we i cause i see
this question a lot like why should
people
try to encourage engagement either in
the comments the like button etc
uh i mean they should encourage
engagement because it's giving youtube
the triggers that people like this
content so if people are liking it then
what youtube says is ah
this sally likes it we should also then
show this
video to rick because rick also kind of
likes stuff like this and it actually
doesn't it helps you um to get your
content out in those browse and
suggested uh um uh uh
tabs no it does not browse and suggested
features more i guess is the right word
for it
absolutely and you know what's also
interesting is that yes these videos are
side by side right now but it's not fair
because this one just came out today on
the left here but you know what's cool
is that you have your views per hour so
you have the videos you made a while ago
getting a lot of views right now
and they don't line up with the ones
getting high engagement so what do you
do with that information well you try to
take the videos that you're going to
double down on
and you try to take the tactics from
these videos that are working in terms
of engagement and you combine them for
your next video
and that's why i love a tool like this
because it takes the data that youtube
is already giving you and it moves it
around in a way that is very
comprehensive and very interesting and
then another one i love to consider is
the subscribers gained a lot of us with
here want subscribers right well these
videos
are bringing in the majority of our
subscribers in the last 30 days
this is some of the damage that these
videos have done and that is awesome to
see so again
what is going on in these videos maybe
there was a call to action just at the
right time or maybe because these are
more of our search based videos maybe
that's bringing in a lot of new people
so we're getting a lot of new
subscribers from that so many things to
know and then of course
another column to check out is
competitors by vph you thanks to our
competitors tool populate this list so
we put other channels that we think make
similar content to us and we put them in
the competitors list and once we do that
the channel audit tool which i have
completely lost
shows up
your competitors so you kind of curated
this list and now we're seeing these
shorts that colin smear doing are just
kicking our butts
so again maybe maybe a short strategy
coming soon who knows there's a lot of
data to dive into here and we won't go
into it all right now but we also have
con like content that could use work so
things that didn't didn't perform very
well what we can learn from that
all of this stuff this is this is min
maxing right here this is how you get
your channel
to grow by taking this information
looking at it purely as data i like to
try and remove the emotional uh aspect
from the content like i have an
emotional attachment to what i'm doing
right but i try to remove that when i'm
in data mode and pull it all together
and see how can i make my next video
encompass all the things that are
working across my channel
yeah and you know a lot of people ask
like i can't figure out what videos to
make i can't figure out why my channel
is not growing and i'm like you should
have tools like this that are actually
giving you the data and removing like
you said the emotion stand our audience
needs to know though what is that this
is this is tool 2a what is the cool
magnifying glass plug-in app that you're
using that is showing uh those those
pieces
i think if you were to look up hover
zoom
okay it would come up i spent forever
trying to find this because i asked rob
wilson has this on his browser i'm like
that i need that that's so cool and i
couldn't find it anywhere it took so
long so i just right click it and it
says magnifying glass and then in
parentheses hover zoom so okay look in
the chrome extensions be very careful by
the way when downloading random
extensions from some stranger on the
internet okay just be sure to do your
research on that one but it it works
it's hover zoom
i love it i love it i'm gonna get that
too um does vidiq work in other
languages yes ricky it does answered
that one for you um how often does it
really update so how often does that
update happen i think it's i mean i'm
not looking at it more than every
probably every two days i'm not really
in that one as as much as i am for the
real-time analytics or things like that
uh yeah i guess i don't know if you mean
daily ideas or the channel audit tool
the channel audit tool is updating with
your channel so as you're making videos
and things like that it's just it's
always in the window of wherever you set
it last 30 days 60 days 90 days
the daily ideas tool
every time you check that you can
potentially see 50 new ideas
and yes sometimes the ai
takes ideas it gave you it gets jumbled
around it's it's ai it is learning of
course but generally speaking 50 new
ideas uh it should be daily
and 50 is a lot i mean you don't need 50
idea you do need 50. but it's it's it's
helping you really just get your um get
the ideas flowing i want to say also uh
latonya thank you so much for super chat
you can do super chat at any time by
clicking the uh little
what is that called money signal i don't
know what it's called other than like
little money symbol uh part of it uh any
other tools from vid iq
that was the list i had pulled up let me
just double check that information yes
that was the list i had pulled up so
good well you can give it iq uh if you
can get 30 days a free trial so someone
said i just really can't afford that yet
download our free trial of an iq and get
30 days and use it and see how much your
channel could grow it's really such a
great tool i highly recommend it just on
that point real quick sorry like
the way i like to think of it is if
you're at a point in your youtube
journey where you don't feel like you
want to invest that much in a tool like
that that's totally cool that's what the
free version's for and you can let this
subscription kind of grow with you as
your channel's growing you can then
decide if this is something you want to
put a little bit of money in there's a
few different tiers of subscription but
i totally understand that you should be
investing in what is the mo the top
priority for your channel for a lot of
people that's like microphones or
cameras or things like that
totally get it definitely try the free
version
and i actually love this comment you've
sold me tubebuddy has never given me
that info uh i've never liked uh never
man i just cannot talk today dan i'm
just like trying to read and talk at the
same time um but disciple really excited
that you're gonna be part of the vid iq
family um i think that they are such a
wonderful uh company because of all
these different pieces and i still use
them every single day as a content
creator actually i was just writing up
uh different videos that were doing for
a brand deal and i was like vid iq let's
go there because it makes it so easy um
for us to do all right number three the
tool you need as a youtube content
creator and i say you should use this
tool um over things like photoshop or
over uh really complex uh different
softwares because
canva.com dan
blows my mind with the things that you
can do on canva.com um i'm gonna pull it
up really quick so you can see what it
looks like and the reason i think that
you should use this now i understand if
you are a graphic designer and your tool
is photoshop or you're into lightroom or
whatever the things are nowadays that
all the cool kids are using uh you
definitely want to check this out
because it does more than just youtube
but what's so cool over actually on
think media we have an entire playlist
for you of how you can use canva so
nolan from our team has gone through how
to create your channel banner art um how
to create your end cards using that i
actually did a quick 13 minute tutorial
teaching you exactly how to make a
thumbnail with that and then we've even
done how to make your intro with canva
so there's so many different ways that
you can use this software but we were
talking dan a little bit before about
increasing your impressions or i'm sorry
increasing your click-through rate rate
my goodness
tongue-tied today increasing your
click-through rate why are thumbnails so
important we talked about titles a
little bit because of what vidiq can
help you really craft but why thumbnails
also
you know i've been trying to find a way
to explain this like the the most
efficient way to explain why
thumbnails are so important you know
because i used to treat them like
my book needs a cover and i don't have
time to make one right now so i'm just
gonna slap something together right but
the thumbnail i want you to think of the
thumbnail as
just another content opportunity and
what i mean by that is if you make a
video right it's it is content it is
about something and the title and the
thumbnail are meant to sell people on
that idea of clicking on it watching it
watching it through
you can play with those you can have the
title and the thumbnail play off of each
other and i really wish i brought an
example as i'm saying this but
you don't have to you you can do one of
two things you can either have the
thumbnail be a visual representation of
your title which is very wise and you
know
logical or you can have the thumbnail
and the title require one another to
exist to coexist and you could have the
title saying one thing and the thumbnail
supporting what the title is saying or
vice versa so these two things do go
hand in hand we did talk about titles
like you said the thumbnail people
people are very visual and the thumbnail
is super super important uh
so canva being out there for free is
incredible because this is something
people should absolutely be thinking
about it so for example the best new
iphone microphones for video
best iphone mics
arrow pointing at the microphone you see
an iphone i don't need to read the title
of that video
the the
supports exactly what the title is
saying and doing uh and then how to
record a powerpoint presentation free
and easy record powerpoint
that's everything i need to know right
there like these this this is how
you put together a thumbnail very high
quality the colors the the framing of
your thumbnail everything all this stuff
matters
yeah it really does and what i love uh
one of the cool features about gamma now
again back to the idea that uh you know
youtube is
um a place where you can start for free
you can start a lot of different free
tools canva has a free option vidiq has
a free option but if you want to go all
in if you're like no this is the thing
i'm gonna go all in and it becomes an
investment opportunity for you then i
highly recommend updating your canva as
well they have a free version but the
pro version i think is like 12 a month
it's very inexpensive when it comes to
that and it opens up a lot of features
and actually one of my favorite features
is um when you go to canva let me just
show you guys real quick how easy this
is you say youtube uh thumbnails it's
gonna give you a youtube thumbnail and
you could um let's say i wanna do uh i
mean gosh there's so many options oh
this is a really good one okay i'm gonna
use this custom thumbnail and you're
gonna see that it's gonna have this
guy's face on it well that's not me dan
so i gotta like actually get my face on
here so let me go here and i'm gonna go
down and i'm gonna put actually i'll do
sean and sean bradley let's do let's do
these two because i mean come on my god
son's so cute isn't he look at this oh
my goodness the cutest okay but look how
cool this is if you go to image you can
hit remove background and it's actually
gonna remove the background so you're
like how did how did they get those
super um crispy lines around people it's
gonna actually go through and it's gonna
remove the background from this image
it's pulling it right now it's trying to
decide what is a background what is not
a background and we can just stare at
sean bradley's face because this isn't
either cutest but look at this we could
actually do this
and then bam thumbnail ready to
go how cool is that feature when it
comes to being able to create youtube
thumbnails i think it's really awesome
when you can have different elements
right color matters that was why i
picked that one too like such a cool
bright color removes the background from
it and makes it more quote-unquote
professional when it comes to a youtube
um thumbnail what are some other
elements that you really like on
thumbnail stan
i i you know going back to the thumbnail
you just had i i think less is more and
the there were three elements to the
thumbnail you had the picture of
you know your talent in the video you
have the text
supporting what the title is saying and
ideally you're not repeating the title
text in the text of the thumbnail but
just a few words with a nice bold font
and then the background something bright
and colorful
or sometimes it is kind of like the
picture you had there there was you know
blurred background sometimes that works
too but only a couple elements and and
you'd be amazed at how often people
overcomplicate thumbnails and
the canva templates if nothing else
let's say you look at this template like
that's not really for me if nothing else
the camel canva templates we saw are all
very simple they they do a very good job
of simplifying
thumbnails and
think about it think about the size of a
thumbnail how small that is on a mobile
phone
how many elements can you really cram
onto that thing
that people are actually going to stop
and like look at right yeah yeah and i i
think what i love too is um canva
actually gives you a bunch of photos and
one of the underrated uh pieces that
people don't actually do on canva i'm
gonna pull it up here is um you could
click this like i don't actually have to
change this if i'm doing i could maybe
change the words of this but i don't
have to be the person in the photo you
know you can actually use different
photos they have a whole different
option of photos that you could be using
so you know maybe you're doing uh
thanksgiving dinner yeah you could just
use this photo or maybe you're talking
about um
maybe you're talking about you know
mystery or something like that you could
use different photos that are available
right here on the platform as well so
there's so many different pieces but
thumbnails matter that if there's one
thing i want you to get it's that
thumbnails really matter when it comes
to this and we actually look looks like
our uh community dan is already using
canva which is amazing because it makes
it super easy um to do thumbnails uh for
their uh for their youtube channel so
we've gone through all three of them uh
thank you dan for uh being a part of the
growth video live show today um i'm
gonna say thank you also we had a
starred comment here thank you so much
for your super chat
uh thank you think media and vid iq uh
you use this by insta on it and jumped
views by 30 to 50 plus wow 30 to 50 plus
that's incredible um we also have vid iq
is a must-have if you're a serious
content creator my views went up
exponentially after i learned keyword
search tags and key phrases in the title
um let's see
i thought there was another question
about bid iq want to make sure i get
that for you uh oh yeah canva is 13.99
and anything else you want to add today
dan on any of those tools that we use or
um advice for new content creators
well
uh
i when you said that i'm like oh i could
show
the thumbnail preview tool because we
did just talk about thumbnails if you
want
we i know the tool demonstration portion
is over
but at the same time this is the encore
this is the encore okay fantastic then
so let's go back to the video we were
trying not to break earlier
uh
what i love is you get you get your
title you get everything set up uh we
call this the thumbnail preview tool but
really it lets you preview all kinds of
stuff in search results and so i have
our earlier title we were playing with
here how to promote your youtube channel
so the way this works is
you want to type something in here that
you feel like a person is going to type
in so you're not typing the title of
your video necessarily you're trying to
rank for the term promote your youtube
channel so in fact i'll just get rid of
how to promote your youtube channel
right someone may type that into search
when you click preview and search
results
the way it works is you see this kind of
light gray outline on on this video
that's your video pretending it's going
to rank
in the second spot so this video isn't
published right now and it's just
showing you if your video happens to
rank well for this term it'll show up
amongst these videos right so how to
promote your youtube videos in google
ads how to promote your youtube channel
1000 subscribers fast how to promote
your youtube channel and then we're
looking at the titles we're looking at
the thumbnails of these videos now
obviously we're not it's not a good
comparison because i didn't use a real
video example for this
but again you can use this before you
publish your video so once you've made
your canva thumbnail and you feel like
you're happy with it throw it on your
video don't publish it yet type in a few
different search terms you want to rank
for and see how it looks amongst all
these other thumbnails would you click
on your thumbnail be honest with
yourself would you click on your
thumbnail versus
this thumbnail or this thumbnail it's
a fantastic tool and it works in so many
different ways like you can see the home
screen we can turn off competitors we
can just see what our video looks like
amongst
what a home screen could show you right
and then you can even see it in
different formats
as well so i just wanted to show that
off uh you mentioned what else i'd say
about thumbnails make sure your thumb
you do your research and your thumbnail
that you've created looks good and
presents itself amongst its competition
appropriately
wow i i actually didn't even know that
tool existed dan so now i'm gonna go and
make sure that the thumbnails are
working before we even post it so you
went there and what did you click on
when you were here on this screen
so we're in the edit yeah edit yes we're
editing the video and it's the preview
and search results and i think while
you're uploading the video it shows up
somewhere else in the upload window i
usually use it in here so forgive me but
yes uh it's always there for you once
you post a video or before you post a
video oh my goodness i love that so much
well thank you so much dan for being a
part of the growth video live show we
are less than 30 days away you can get
your virtual ticket or your in-person
ticket um right now if you use the code
uh gwvlshow
and you can get five percent off right
now it's 50 off of tickets and you can
get 55 for being a viewer of today's
show thank you so much dan for being on
today love always having our guests from
vid iq um over here and you can check
out dan over on the vid iq channel just
go to youtube.com forward slash
vidiq and that's where you can find um
all the great information more about
their tools and things that they are
doing over on youtube well thank you so
much for watching and we'll catch you in
the next video do you want to get in the
room with experts like gary vaynerchuk
patrickbetdavid vanessa lau pat flynn
chalene johnson and more and would you
like to meet hundreds of other creative
entrepreneurs just like you well then do
not miss the chance to get around
creators and business influencers at
growth video live 2022 conference you
can actually lock in your limited
discounted tickets at
growethvideolive.com or you can click
the link in this post or in the
description now if you want to learn the
best new strategies for getting views on
youtube and the most proven and
profitable ways to grow online then do
not miss this life changing event you
can join us in person in las vegas or
virtually from around the world secure
your ticket at grossvideolive.com
and take the fast track to dominating
the next decade not just with youtube
but with video go to growthvideolive.com
or click the link in this poster in the
description to secure your limited time
discounted ticket